it was love at first sight wasn't it
it's a beautiful night
just you
a bottle of wine and your partner
drifting through the cosmos in a ufo as
you caress their green skin
you know that tonight's the night you're
mating with an alien
but
would your anatomy be compatible
how would conception take place
and
what would your child look like
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you made it with an alien
okay so
maybe an intimate alien encounter
wouldn't work out that way
but if you believe the statistics
six percent of americans have allegedly
been abducted by aliens
according to these victims
the experiences were
intrusive and
horrifying why would an alien want to
mate with a human
well if these aliens wanted to settle on
earth
interbreeding could speed up the process
yeah the child would have the best of
both worlds
combining our dna could create a hybrid
being that could survive in the hottest
climates
and maybe your kids would get the
intelligence of an alien
they flew across the universe in a tin
plate they have to be a little bright
but even if your offspring became a
genius
would society ever accept them
hybridization occurs when two different
species breed and it's more common than
you might think
we crossbreed fruits and animals all the
time but this isn't like your mom's
labradoodle
you would be mating with a being from
another galaxy so
what are the consequences of this
pairing
well first forget the wine and dine
scenario from before
the only way you could mate with e.t
would be through artificial insemination
after all all of our parts may not be
compatible so whether your seed was
placed in an alien or vice versa
medical procedures would be the only way
to bring your child into this world
unfortunately the real threat to this
kid's health could lie within you
sometimes a mother's blood can produce
antibodies that destroy their baby's
blood cells
in humans we call this condition rhesus
disease
introducing a completely different blood
type and dna into a human mother
could trigger their immune system to
reject this perceived alien intruder
and if their body kept the baby alive
long enough to fully form
the next challenge
would be getting it out
a childbirth with human babies can be
difficult enough
a hybrid birth would definitely cause
complications
to keep the baby hybrid and its mother
safe during labor
doctors would have to perform a cesarean
section
yeah those big gray heads aren't getting
through a birth canal provided those are
some of the physical features your baby
would have
the first generation of hybrids would
still look like their alien side of the
family but the second generation could
look so close to humans you may not even
tell the difference
they might be able to blend into a crowd
although our entire society could change
with aliens walking among us
and
this may not be the first time humans
have mated outside our species in modern
history
yeah rumors still float around about
florida scientists who artificially
inseminated a chimpanzee with human dna
in the 1920s
while we may never know the truth behind
this experiment
were it true
this humanzee would have been an ethical
nightmare
cool name though
a human alien hybrid could hold the
answer to our survival on a changing
earth or even beyond the stars
the cultural and physical differences
might be too much to accept at first
remember we all still carry the genes of
neanderthals in our dna the last traces
of this long extinct species that lived
alongside humans tens of thousands of
years ago
but hey we got over that problem
so what if you made it with a
neanderthal instead
well
pop a breath mint and freshen up because
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]
you